hallo freunde der sonne ich bin zwar
wieder eure chemikerin das vertrauen
ich habe vor anderthalb jahren dieses
video über floride und zahnpasta gemacht
und seitdem werde ich immer wieder nach
oben ziehen gefragt beim öl ziehen nimmt
man einen löffel kokosöl sesamöl oder
irgendein anderes natürliches öl und
zieht sich das ein paar minuten lang
durch die zähne
bevor man es wieder ausspuckt weil das
gut für die zähne und vieles mehr sein
soll ich kann dir das selbst lage nicht
also in meinem freundeskreis ist öl
zielen nicht wirklich verbreitet was
wahrscheinlich daran liegt dass der aus
vielen chemikern besteht
findet ihr es nicht eklig dass wir mit
unseren titel mein wohnzimmer
kontaminieren und chemikalien schnell
dazu natürliche sachen zu belächeln
dabei ist das natürlich genauso falsch
wie die generelle vorstellung dass alles
natürliche viel sand der ist als ob
irgendwas aus der natur kommt oder aus
dem labor spielt erstmal keine rolle
[Musik]
der sei will ich hier mal ganz
unvoreingenommen rangehen und zum glück
gibt es zum thema öl ziehen ein paar
wissenschaftliche studien die mir helfen
werden das heißt ihr wisst was jetzt
kommt ist immer wieder zeit für
wissenschaftlich geprüft ich werde mir
diese studien genauer anschaut und dann
am ende öl ziehen scientific abrufen
oder auch nichts los geht's öl ziehen
ist eine traditionelle praxis aus der
ayurvedischen lehre die aus indien
stammt inzwischen habe hierzulande auch
ganz beliebt ist der das öl soll nicht
nur essensreste und schmutz aus den
szenen ziehen sondern auch bakterien und
giftstoffe soll nicht nur weißere zähne
machen und gehen karies und zahnfleisch
sondern noch sehr viel mehr das
immunsystem stärken die hormonhaushalt
regulieren kopfschmerzen reduzieren mehr
energie liefern und und und letztere
sachen klingen sehr esoterisch aber
tatsächlich gibt es ganz interessante
zusammenhänge zwischen einem gesunden
mund und einem gesunden körper zum
beispiel geht parodontitis tatsächlich
einher mit einem erhöhten risiko für
bestimmte krankheiten zum beispiel
herzerkrankungen diabetes alzheimer
klingt verwunderlich doch es gibt
verschiedene mögliche verknüpfung zum
beispiel könnte eine entzündung im mund
sowie jede entzündung im körper das
immunsystem und damit auch den ganzen
körper belasten oder die bakterien die
parodontitis auslösen könnten über die
blutbahn auch in andere teile des
körpers gelangen durch die genauen
komplexen zusammenhänge das wäre stoff
für ein eigenes video zum einfluss von
öl ziehen auf dinge wie immunsystem und
so weiter gibt es allerdings keine
forscher überhaupt keine forschung
deswegen entspringen sämtliche claims
die man im internet so findet höchstens
persönliche auffassung des wegen haken
wir mal alle effekte von öl ziehen die
über den mond hinaus gehen ab als nordic
ruft dazu gibt es derzeit keine
wissenschaftlichen belege aber wie sieht
es mit zahnhygiene aus hey ich kann mir
zumindest theoretisch vorstellen wie öl
ziehen funktionieren könnte man kann ja
stoffe einteilen in hydrophilen
hydrophil heißt
wörtlich übersetzt wasser liebend
hydrophob war verhaftet
metro fielen sie drauf gehen also nicht
so gut zusammen da öl sehr hydrophob ist
könnte es sachen aufnehmen die durch
wasser nicht so leicht entfernt sind
das könnten essensreste sein das könnten
auch batterien sowie zahnpasta enthält
schließt sich auch tenside also moleküle
die sowohl hydrophil als auch im topf
sind also sich sowohl mit dem wasser als
auch mit dem schmutz gut verstehen dreck
schmutz weg ab fette öle also alles was
ich nicht so gut in wasser ist das alles
wird an dem inneren der zelle
eingeschlossen und mit dem wasserweg
tenside sind sowieso total cool also wer
mehr dazu wissen will und ganz nebenbei
noch lernen möchte wie man inhaltsstoffe
auf kosmetikprodukten richtig liest
sollte sich mal dieses video reinziehen
durch das ziehen also durch diese
physikalische behandlung wird das öl
außerdem emuliert also es bietet sich
eine illusion
eine feine mischung ausfüllen und was
sieht man auch daran dass das ganze noch
einer zeit milchig wird das öl wird
quasi zerrissen in viele kleine
öltröpfchen so dass es viel mehr
relative oberfläche gewinnt über das es
sachen aufnehmen könnte soviel zur
hypothese aber funktioniert das auch in
der praxis tatsächlich gibt es dazu
einige studien schauen wir uns zuerst
die studien zu allgemeiner mundhygiene
und gesundheit an und am ende gucken wir
noch was es mit dieser zahnaufhellung
auf sich hat jetzt ist ja studier nicht
gleich studie verschiedene studien haben
verschiedene studien designs und damit
auch verschieden große aussagekraft
treue freunde der sonne wissen dass
randomisierte kontrollierte studien als
goldstandard gehandelt werden und bei
der forschungsfrage ist öl ziehen gut
für hygiene und gesundheit ist es nur
sinnvoll sich nur randomisierte
kontrollierte studien anzuschauen denn
nur sie haben bei diesem thema
ausreichend große aussagekraft denn weiß
nicht größere beobachtungsstudien oder
ähnliches gibt es bei diesem thema nicht
ich habe mir alle studien durchforstet
und muss zuerst sagen randomisierte
kontrollierte studien gibt es leider
nicht viele also gut untersucht ist
dieses thema bisher noch nicht aber die
studien die es gibt die kommen
größtenteils zu einem ähnlichen ergebnis
und das ist ganz in
sand aber bevor ich euch das verrate
müssen die erstmal verstehen was genau
in diesen studien gemessen wurde denn
ein einfaches meine telefon sich viel
besser an ist ja viel zu unspezifisch
man kann zum beispiel den sogenannten
plaques index bestimmen
ihr erinnert euch unsere zähne sind
umgeben von einem bio vielen namens
plugged krack niedriger der plaques
index desto weniger kalk und desto
besser die mundhygiene dann gibt es noch
den sogenannten ging die wahl index der
auskunft gibt über die gesundheit der
zahnfleisches kleine stinker außerdem
wissen wir vor diesem video in
berghausen viele kleine mikroorganismen
die zum beispiel den zahnschmelz
anknabbern und karies verursachen
deshalb lohnt es sich auch anhand eines
speichel abstrichs die anzahl bestimmter
bakterien zu bestimmen zum beispiel von
streptococcus mutans das sind ihn ja ich
sag mal haupt karies bakterien und auch
mundgeruch ist ein faktor beim und
hygiene und gesundheit und wird gemessen
da gibt es verschiedene messmethoden
entweder subjektiv in dem die
versuchsteilnehmer einen geruch spüren
anhusten oder dich selbst beurteilen in
dem die teilnehmer an ihrem handgelenk
lecken und anschließend am getrockneten
speichel riechen gibt es zum glück auch
noch objektive messmethode für den
mundgeruch nehme ich auch wieder durch
bestimmung von bakterien die jetzt
besonders für mundgeruch verantwortlich
sind also seht es gibt tatsächlich
mehrere wissenschaftlichen messmethoden
um zu bestimmen wie jetzt die situation
hier aussieht ok zurück zu unseren
studien ich habe rund zehn randomisierte
kontrollierte studien gefunden die aber
nicht alle gerade genannten messmethoden
durchgeführt haben sondern manche haben
zum beispiel nur dem plug-in nichts
bestimmt andere haben nur die
streptokokken bakterien gemessen und so
weiter bei den meisten studien würde das
öl ziehen so angewendet einmal täglich
vor dem zähneputzen über einen zeitraum
von einer oder mehreren wochen als
kontrolle wurde entweder konventionelles
mundwasser verwendet und zwar mundwasser
mit dem antibakteriellen wirkstoff
chlorhexidin oder auch nur wasser da
habe ich mich jetzt gefragt beim öl
ziehen weiß ich nicht es könnte gerne in
die kommentare schreiben wann man das
macht aber und wasser benutzt man doch
nach dem zähneputzen oder oder es hält
so eine große debatte die
die bevölkerung spaltet wie wann
benutzbaren zahnseide vor oder nach und
zähneputzen ganz klar vor dem
zähneputzen team vor dem zähneputzen
die ergebnisse waren das öl ziehen hatte
in den meisten studien einen
vergleichbaren effekt wie das mundwasser
dh im vergleich zu spülen mit normalem
wasser ließen sich sowohl mit öl ziehen
als auch mit mundwasser verbesserte
mundhygiene werte messen ja also von
plaques index über bakterien anzahl so
alles was ich euch gerade erzählt hat
mundgeruch und so weiter das war jetzt
erst mal eine gute nachricht sein für
alle die wie ich finden das mit wasser
viel zu brutal ist es gibt ja auch so
softm und spielerin die man durchaus
länger im mund haben kann aber wonach
sich der mond auch nicht wirklich
frische anfühlt oder es gibt diese
brutalen mundspülungen ich noch nicht
mal für paar sekunden im mund behalten
kann ich verstehen war nicht wie leute
das machen also bin ich die einzige der
es so geht das nicht bei euch dafür muss
man ja auch nicht super lang spielen
also in den studien zum beispiel wurde
das mit wasser meistens für eine minute
angewendet beim öl ziehen sieht es aber
ganz anders aus die anwendungs zeit in
den studien waren fünf bis zehn minuten
lang also ist es normal falls ihr unter
euch sehen schreiben in die kommentare
wie lange wir das so macht außerdem fand
ich jetzt also ich habs jetzt zum ersten
mal probiert dieses gefühl von reinem öl
auf der zunge
also mittel geil ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber die studien
sagen öl ziehen kann die mundhygiene
messbar verbessern also ab ruft aber
zwei achtungs achtung nummer 1 es gibt
bisher nicht nur wenige studien auch die
teilnehmerzahl dieser studien hauen
einig wirklich vom brocke also die
meisten stunden haben so 20 bis 40
teilnehmer das ist statistisch nicht
besonders stark deshalb bisher aber nur
mit ausdrücklichem zusatz power research
und achtung nummer zwei grundwasser ist
nicht nur keine ausreichende zahnpflege
sondern mundwasser könnte möglicherweise
sogar zu viel des guten sein in dieser
studie von 2017 wird zum beispiel davor
gewarnt das mundwasser das risiko für
diabetes erhöhen
könnte es wird vermutet dass mundwasser
auch die guten bakterien gilt was dann
negativen einfluss auf den ganzen körper
haben könnte also da wären wir wieder
bei dieser interessanten verknüpfung
zwischen mund und körper hier ist jetzt
auch erstmal nur research needed aber
wenn jetzt öl ziehen tatsächlich
vergleichbar messbaren effekt hat wie
mundwasser dann ist es nicht
auszuschließen dass das auch
vergleichbare nebeneffekte haben könnte
war einen klaren vorteil gibt es wohl
von öl ziehen gegenüber mundwasser denn
zumindest mundwasser mit chlorhexidin
kann auch zu unerwünschten verfärbungen
führen und damit kommen wir zu der frage
macht öl ziehen die zähne wirklich
weißer ist die wissenschaftliche lage
wieder etwas enttäuschend ich habe
tatsächlich nur eine studie gefunden und
das ist auch nur eine in vitro studien
das heißt man hat hier menschliche zähne
im labor untersucht und mit
verschiedenen dingen behandelt also mit
wasserstoffperoxid also einen wirksamen
bleichmittel als positive kontrolle dann
mit kokosöl sesamöl und sonnenblumenöl
und dann noch als negative kontrolle mit
einer salzlösung die öle schnitten hier
nicht besser ab als die kontrolle also
es gab keine nennenswerte aufhellung im
gegensatz zum gleich mittel das heißt
hier nord prüft aber auch ganz klar
more research needed denn man sollte ihn
ebenso einer in vitro studie das ganze
auch mal im großen maßstab in vivo also
mit menschen untersuchen aber das wurde
bisher noch nicht gemacht aber auch hier
kann ich nur wiederholen ich meine
schaut meine zähne an alles was ihr
dafür braucht es einen guten
weißabgleich zumindest sind bisher keine
nebenwirkungen von benzin bekannt wobei
es jetzt auch nicht so verwunderlich ist
weil das thema ja noch nicht so gut
untersucht ist also ich benutze wie
gesagt kein mit wasser und werde jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mit umziehen
anfangen schließlich reicht ordentliches
zähneputzen für einen gesunden bund mein
persönliches fazit ist mond wasser oder
öl ziehen kann man machen kann man auch
lassen was in eure erfahrungen mit
mundwasser oder öl ziehen und vor allem
was soll ich als nächstes
wissenschaftlich prüfen schreibt es in
die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche und bis
dahin sicher
klack klack klack klack klack